welcome back to the gadget lab i'm
michael colori i'm christina bonnington
this week we've got a look at the brand
new macbook pro with retina display with
the retina display then we're going to
take a quick look at a really crazy cool
water gun and then we're going to come
back and talk about the enhancements to
apple's operating systems that were
announced
at the worldwide developers conference
you were there yes monday morning bright
and early kind of
and uh you came back with a treat i did
this is the new macbook pro with retina
display it's
super thin 0.71 inches thin and it
weighs about a pound less than current
15-inch macbook pros it's 4.46 pounds so
it's it's actually you know it may not
show up as well on screen but it's
remarkably thinner than
the the previous one and it looks a lot
more like an air i mean it's not
wedge-shaped like the area is but just
the styling of it i think yeah
and of course that written the display
yeah
show it off show it off all right let's
see what we got here
um yeah so it's four times as many
pixels as the current macbook pros
it's
one wait no 5 million 184 000 pixels
and it's
it's just so many pixels you can you
it's
it's crazy you guys yeah so the thing
the thing about it is like you really
you have to read something like read a
web page on it because you know there's
a lot of people talking about how photos
aren't going to look as sharp or icons
aren't going to look as sharp and that's
true um things that haven't yet been
optimized for the retina display aren't
going to look as stunning on a retina
display you'll you'll see artifacts and
look a little grungy but anything that's
scalable graphics so like uh you know
flash animations
uh anything saved in the svg image
format but text is super super sharp and
it's really amazing like when you're
when you're scrolling i noticed um you
know just how how brilliant the the text
is it is it's
just looking at gmail on an old macbook
pro compared to this one it's just a
night and day difference it's so much
easier to read on this on this one how
much is it gonna suck when you have to
give it back
it'll be real sad twenty two hundred
dollars for the starting model twenty
two hundred dollars yeah can we talk
about that for a minute yeah
that's a lot of dough to swallow for a
new notebook um
you know and
really do you need all those pixels and
you know just like a pound less of
notebook so when are they putting out
the retina in the air which is the the
macbook air is like
what 1200 for the
for the larger screen and for the the 11
inch screen it's a thousand dollars
isn't that going to get a bread in
display sometime soon i definitely i
would probably expect macbook airs to
get a retina display update maybe within
the next year or two not not more than
two years okay um
it's just fitting all that tech into the
smaller form factor you know i see so
speaking of all the tech that's inside
the smaller form factor uh there's a bit
of a uh controversy about the inside
right yes
um
this is
rated by ifixit as the least repairable
laptop they've ever seen
and these are the guys that that as soon
as anything comes out they pop it open
with their screwdrivers and take a look
at everything that's inside yeah and so
the problem is all these parts are glued
um there's you know parts layered
together so if you try to remove one
thing
excuse me um if you try to take one part
out you know you're going to break
something else in the process
um so what if i want to add more ram
nope you're out of luck what if i want
to swap out the ssd for like a terabyte
ssd
no can't do it
what if i want to replace the battery
nope i just have to buy a new one yeah
maybe take it to applecare but we're
talking about really so i gotta like
take it into the app store and pay the
flat fee and all that yeah yeah but i
just spent like 2500 on this damn thing
it's true but you're paying 2500
for what apple has given you why would
you want to change that oh yeah you're
right they know best that's that's the
message here i'm taking it i think so
all right um is there anything else we
want to say about this uh other than
you've got a full review coming we've
got a full review coming um let's see
it's um it's fast it's it's really fast
um
yeah core i7 processor
flash memory
i'm a big fan of keyboard actually just
in a couple of minutes i've spent with
it so far i think the keyboard and the
trackpad you know as always apple is the
best in the business at the input
devices in the in the screen yeah so
anyway um you can read christina's full
review of the macbook air but the
macbook pro
with retina display uh that will be up
very soon on the product reviews website
on wired.com
and now i believe you're going to take
us outdoors and show us a squirt gun yep
it's june it's hot outside it's a
perfect weather for a trip to the beach
or the park
for father's day growing up my family
would always get dad a nerf super soaker
this year we've got the nerf super
soaker lightning storm it's 25
has a 32 ounce water clip and it even
has a blast shield we've also got the 10
nerf super soaker electrostorm the only
problem with these guys is they just
don't hold enough water but it's still
great fun
we are
we won't win
so is that a real super soaker it is a
real super soaker and it's only 25
i remember like the old ones in the 90s
they had these giant
you know like backpack systems and
everything and they were like 100 over a
hundred dollars yeah i know that's very
affordable get one for the whole family
let's go back to the
wwdc
so it wasn't all about hardware it
wasn't so apple introduced ios 6 for the
first time
and spent a lot of the presentation
focusing on that it's got a lot of cool
features
one of them is the new maps app
apple
has developed its own maps app from the
ground
up it's got this cool 3d flyover feature
where you can see like 3d buildings and
stuff in major metropolitan areas
yeah i don't know how useful it'll be in
actually getting to your destination but
i could see wasting a lot of time just
like scrolling through paris or
something you know i do that already in
the google maps app on the phone but you
know i have to say i think that the the
the maps app that they're dumping the
google one that comes standard on the
phone already is awesome yeah so it's
apples is going to have to be like
doubly kick-ass in order for it to
actually
trump what's already available i think
right
otherwise i'm just going to be going to
the app store and downloading the google
apps app unless of course they block it
which they would never do yeah i don't
think they can do that um well they
could but they wouldn't get away with it
right right
uh
there was also um announced the
mountain lion
that's right the new version of osx
yes um so the developer preview has been
out since february but they showed off
some of its major new features um
there's a lot of
kind of like back and forth between ios
and mac in mountain lion so there's a
lot of like in safari there's sharing
shared bookmarks um
your browsing history is shared on both
so if you if you google you know how to
bake a pie on your iphone and then
you're like oh what was that great site
i found your history is right there
when you get when you sign back onto
your mac your mountain lion
a lot of this i mean we've seen this
before on android with the latest
versions of androids with chrome browser
where chrome can talk between open tabs
on the phone or open tabs on the desktop
and
uh just so sort of an ecosystem all
coming together now finally yeah and
safari added the chrome like uh
searching in the url bar oh finally
finally i've been waiting for that for
eons and mountain lion is coming out
when
next month and it's only 20
it's uh like osx lion last year it is
just a download from the mac app store
and the one-time purchase
applies to all of your macs so if you
have a if you have multiple macs
20 bucks
mountain lion on all of them that's
great that's a bargain
yeah definitely when is ios 6 arriving
that should be arriving in the fall and
i would definitely expect that to be
arriving with the next iphone
so
maybe september october is when we're
expecting that oh but it's not going to
work on older devices right right well
so you'll probably be able to download
ios 6
but a lot of the main like flagship
features like some like flyover in the
maps app um are only going to work on
like the iphone 4s or higher or the ipad
2 or higher so your older 3gs and iphone
4 aren't going to get the full
functionality of ios 6. right limited
love for the old devices yeah yeah you
know they're
ancient they're injured by this point
that's true and you really are missing
out if you don't have the latest
hardware it's you know just sort of the
the law of consumer electronics
unfortunately as much as people hate it
uh that's all that's all that we have
time for this week uh we'll be back next
week where we will have not so much
apple news but probably a little bit
about the news
anyway until then bye-bye
foreign